[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy tuesday everyone oh man we have a
classic show for tonight
we have both patty and brown and mike
baker on
yeah
now uh patty ann you remember from red
eye
and she had a way with words
good evening i am sith lord darth
hatties and during the weekdays fox news
anchor patty ann brown the day after red
eyes round table discussion on the
relative sexiness of the fox and friends
staff the new york times erroneously
reported that i said quote brian
kilmeade makes me want to puke in fact i
stated that kill mead makes me want to
shoop i'd also like to add that brian's
packed and he's stacked especially in
the back brother want to thank your
mother for a butt like that straight up
wait up hold up mr lover like prince
said you're a sexy mother
[Applause]
the thing she almost had chris wallace's
job
she's still better than chris wallace
and then mike baker you may remember him
from red eye for his deep insights
when i smoke me some weed the first
thing i want to eat is a hot wing
sandwich
hot wings and he's allowed to carry a
gun
all right to the monologue so in
preparation for the made for prime time
show trial on the january 6 riots house
dems have hired a former abc news
executive james goldston to polish up
their trumped-up turd
their goal take old battered
exaggerations and repurpose it as new
improved outrage what beatlemania was to
the fab four this hearing is to trump
derangement syndrome
keep it going as long as possible to
divert from biden's miseries but it's
nuts a political party secures prime
time real estate on a major network abc
who once employed the producer and it's
also owned by disney can you find a more
obvious case of collusion between party
and the press
the special features interviews and
pre-produced videos and it airs smack
dab at 8pm
i know cat that's opposite young sheldon
[Laughter]
never seen that i don't even know what
that is
but it probably has a million viewers
you know but it's worth it because some
in the media think january 6 is bigger
than all your hardships combined
there are so many things that people are
juggling between gas prices and
inflation baby formula abortion
and
the shootings that are happening
these lawmakers are going to try to now
have a narrative to focus the country's
attention to say look at this thing do
not turn away and understand that while
all those other things are really really
important the foundation of our country
what makes our country function is a
democracy that we have to protect
they got to force feed it
you can't call that state-run propaganda
then what is state-run propaganda
honestly could you imagine the
republican party securing prime time
coverage for a hearing on hunter biden
and how the media claimed his laptop was
rushing to info
of course not the big tech overlords
wouldn't even let you discuss it without
suspending your account
they probably have to air it on animal
planet
how about the biden families china and
ukraine connections that could be a
hearing or a prime time hearing on the
russian collusion hoax that was a slow
rolling coup
you want more how about actual terrorism
and destruction take left-wing attorneys
colin ford mattis and rouge
ramen they were accused of throwing a
molotov cocktail into a police car in
new york and faced domestic terrorism
charges and 30 years in jail but since
they were rioting on behalf of blm and
targeting cops their acts of terrorism
became acts of heroism it's just like
those violent demonstrations when trump
was elected remember that footage the
media doesn't they buried that too you'd
have a better chance of finding
non-alcoholic beer in cat's fridge
but this week the white house agreed to
what jonathan turley calls a
breathtaking reduction in these
terrorist charges that'll likely result
in just a few years of jail time
remember mattis had been accused of
having a pile of firebombs in his car
and was filmed trying to hand him out to
other rioters rahman was caught on
camera throwing bombs and then boasted
about it like she just threw a
one-hitter against the yankees
they pleaded guilty last year to one
count of possessing and making an
explosive device but now they can
withdraw the earlier plea and instead
plead to conspiring to assemble bombs
and damage the patrol car it's like they
were tossing water balloons instead
keep in mind the backdrop for all of
this is trump supporters rotting in jail
for a year and a half for an unguided
often unhinged tour of the capitol
building
if this keeps up these blm bombers will
be sentenced to a romantic vacay in
honolulu
they can make molotov cocktails with
pineapple and paper umbrellas in them
i bring this of course up of course to
show you the sharp difference in
treatment compared to the jan six
protesters you know they were called a
threat to police and indeed some were
but yet here two scum buckets could have
burned officers alive and now their
sentences are closer to tax fraud than
terrorism i doubt abc will devote a
single minute to that
because it's not just about show trials
but no show trials the guy producing
this january 6 special goldstein
presided over abc news up until 2021 and
he was involved in several scandals
notably
a jeffrey epstein cover-up story
remember that video of abc news anchor
amy roback claiming the network killed
her story on epstein and prince andrew's
sexual misconduct on the lolita express
sorry the story wasn't killed
it just hanged itself in itself
see the guy running the car this january
6 comedy hour shows you how the legacy
media works it's about turning on and
off the news faucet jeffrey epstein
turned the faucet off january 6 turn it
on and leave the room until the house is
totally flooded as for everything else
the other riots the crime wave the
border crisis you'll find jimmy hoffa
before you find any of that
instead as they see biden's presidency
imploding they could only do one thing
to save it revive january 6. they got
their work cut out for them but then
again disney is great at producing
fiction
[Applause]
we wouldn't have made it very far
without this former red-eye star former
fox news anchor and author of the
fantastic new book write your own story
how i took control by letting go
paddy and brown
he can kill you with his bare hands and
also his long-winded mumbling
sentences former cia operative a host of
black files declassified on discovery
science channel mike baker
she's like a switchblade sharp dangerous
and you can hide her in your sock
fox news contributor captain
and bear trap sir is cuff links my
massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion
tyrus
p-a-b the notorious p-a-b how you doing
me yeah how you doing good good good
good congrats on the book
the first chapter is harrowing because
it details a very uh problematic
childbirth i'm going to read the whole
thing to you
[Laughter]
that's my t's
everybody likes a good childbirth story
as long as it's a happy ending if you
know what i mean it gets much funnier
after that first trapped chapter the
first chapter is very dramatic i read
the other chapter about red eye as well
just because you're looking for your own
name
and there wasn't an index
which is a problem i would change that
in the paperback just to make it easier
for me so anyway you haven't talked
politics in ages and i bet you're going
aw crap i got to talk politics
a little nervous about the whole cancel
culture thing but you know you won't get
cancelled you will take care that's the
thing i'm a housewife now you're a
housewife although the housewife
association they're a bunch of
sexist
would say oh my god man
[Laughter]
what do you make of this theater it's
like it's kind of it's like the the
hypocrite i mean it's so uh we know this
right it's this is what happens was that
a question
almost yeah i mean what i love is the
fact that trump is supposedly saying
that he is going to counter program yes
i'm not exactly sure where he's doing
that but if he does i would not be
surprised if it got better ratings than
the actual hearing right um but we know
what's going to come out of this hearing
there are thousands and thousands of
hours of videos that we can't see and
people who've seen them say that they
show people being not just escorted in
but some of them are being like shoved
inside against their will
is it true i don't know we can't see
these videos and they're promising never
before seen videos
at this hearing i think they're not
going to be the ones we're looking for i
think you're absolutely right this is
one of those things where they're doing
a mini documentary and whenever you
watch a documentary they're shaping
their narrative mike like people go like
i love documentaries but it's like you
have to understand they've
they're no different than fiction in
many ways because you're shaping the
story much like your hair is so
meticulously cheap no right right and
you are you were just extra hunky today
this is crazy you look like you just
walked out of a viagra commercial
right
you parked your uh just so you can be
ready when the time is right
you parked your classic chevelle outside
the gas station you're picking up some
lambskin yeah it might have been uh
and and some cologne you'll get the
cologne you get the the polo green i
believe do you think do you think people
are going to watch this the democrats
made fun of of uh president trump right
for all those years for hosting a
reality show
and now they're
they're going to host a reality show
right and they're not there there's no
even the slightest effort to hide this
right and they are recasting or they're
trying to recast the whole uh midterm uh
election right uh as
look what the republicans are capable of
doing because in their mind and what
they're trying to get across and they're
using you know some some very clever
messaging i mean it is sort of a
kind of a dictator-like thing to do
right but they're using some very clever
messaging to say basically
look the republican party is the same as
the
morons that wandered around the capitol
yeah right and the last point i'll make
is
they've talked about this incessantly
that
what happened on january 6th
we were this close to losing our
democracy right exactly if that's what
it takes for this country to lose our
democracy we don't deserve the republic
yeah yeah no it's so true it's so true
it's like they uh i think you know
somebody made a good point like we
should ban all the weapons that were
that they used on january
it's just like
which ones look the only person who used
a gun was a cop yeah a capitol hill cop
against an unmarked
an unarmed protester this is a tyrus
would you would you define this as a
show like a theater a theatrical show
no
a show is usually filled with talent and
a good idea and a plot
this is uh
it's it we got two things we have
and we got real
real is two lawyers decided to go out
and make cocktails and blow up a police
car right caught on fire yeah and the
woke left got involved and it's now
conspiracy
to commit which means that they had an
idea of making a car and the fire nobody
was in danger yeah except everyone
within
50 yards of a cop car on fire which
could have exploded because what do cop
cars have in them boys and girls on the
woke side gasoline so it could have
blown up i was going to say doughnuts
okay that's why you
see what i mean and then the other side
you have
everyone involved that did to what we
know that did something went to jail
yeah and no one on the right came and
saved them right most of them are very
mad at the president
saying that mr trump was going to pardon
me he was like you broke the law i'm not
doing nothing for you
that's the difference the left are
protecting their own and disguising it
by making a theatrical presentation
which i'm sure is going to be a lot like
a lot of other times we've seen the only
one i think will be watching with great
anticipation is geraldo because this
will get the jimmy hoffa thing off his
back once
[Applause]
wait
was it jimmy harper al capone al capone
okay phone the safe
sorry
jimmy hoffa it is
you know uh cat i said this a long time
ago he's still looking at me because
he's still looking why is he still
looking at me i said this a long time
ago that if if if the democrats think
you're hitler why wouldn't they rigged
the election and that's that's the thing
it's like if you've been doing for five
years you've been calling everybody
nazis plus you've been creating all
these hoaxes like the fine people hoax
and the russian conclusion oaks why
wouldn't they wriggle an election that
is a that's a legitimate suspicion to
have why do you look so sad cause i'm
freezing
[Laughter]
i'm freezing every day and no one cares
it's hard to be me it is hard to be you
it's hard like it's hard to think when
i'm so cold nope i think what i'm gonna
start doing is getting hand warmers and
taping them to my body underneath my
clothes ah
that's called the bret bear i'm gonna
have to
kat do you want my jacket i i want 11
jackets these are not this is just like
i don't know i got to talk to somebody
about this do you have it i'm going to
do a documentary about that yeah there
you go that'll get a higher rate
i think that um obviously january 6 was
a bad thing i also think that the
framing of a lot of the stuff like in
the new york times at a headline january
6 hearings give democrats a chance to
recast midterm messages exactly which is
like i don't think they're supposed to
say that out loud
you're right
you're right but i think that more
people would be more concerned or more
interested in it if they had faith that
it wouldn't you know be presented in
that way or that it wasn't for that
purpose exactly because i don't think
that largely we are that divided on this
being a bad thing obviously there are
exceptions to that
but i i think that people have
problems in the present that they're
more concerned about than what happened
on january 6. i agree i think that like
no like i don't know a single writer
republican who saw that and didn't turn
go oh that sucks but at the same time
the framing is is reversed they weren't
trying to overthrow the government in
their heads they thought they were
protecting the government from a
fraudulent election if you look at it
that way then you go oh i see and then
they got
like as you said doors were opened and
things in there and then
mostly peaceful how about that why don't
i take their narrative from the left it
was mostly peaceful well yeah look there
there were some that deserved to be
charged right yeah they were and then
there were in jail yeah there were a lot
of people wandering around genuinely
surprised that they were wandering
around inside the capitol
it was it's definitely it was like when
i used to break into the high school gym
[Laughter]
and i did and i won't tell you why
[Laughter]
let's just say i knew where the laundry
was
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else